played by writer director Kevin Smith
and his childhood best friend Jason
Mewes Jay and Silent Bob have been cult
favorites for over two decades appearing
in movies TV shows cartoons and comic
books with no signs of stopping but
what's the real story behind their
popularity he is a look at the untold
truth of Jay and Silent Bob Jay is Jay
mr. bass the loud obnoxious and
aggressive character of Jay are none
other than Jason Mewes himself Muse told
the skinny when we did clerks I was 18
19 that's how I used to act exactly I
didn't have any filter I used to say
stuff exactly like that like what up
this and what at that that stuff I'd
said over the years but Kevin had
written down smoker which mocha wish
doing coke drinkin beer drinkin beers
beers bein rollin fatties one small spot
she smoked was disaster movie myth
famously self-financed clerks which had
a poetry $27,000 budget by selling off
his extensive collection of comic books
pilfering from his college fund and then
maxing out a bunch of credit cards and a
natural disaster also helped Smith
explains and Steven Lowenstein 2002
interview collection my first movie but
the rest of the budget came from an
insurance settlement for a destroyed car
he and Muse shed muse Warren Smith that
the area was going to flood and that
they should move the car Smith said he
didn't want a good thing they didn't
thank you for smoking a stand out
feigning clerks featured an anti-smoking
tirade it delivered by a guy who turns
out to have a self interest in the
matter a representative of chile's a
fictional gun manufacturer it's that
kind of mentality it allows the cancer
producing industry to thrive of course
we're all going to die someday do we
have to pay for it
ironically Smith himself was a nonsmoker
until he filmed clerks
bluffing on screen a silent bob was
enough to get him hooked and he
eventually became a to pack a day smoker
luckily he figured out a way to quit
righty I've been quit smoking out of off
cigarettes for three years and it was
very easy I quit smoking but I just
simply started smoking weed instead Jay
versus Scott evil Smith made clucks
himself so he was free to cast anybody
he wanted but because Grumman
pictures bankrolled the quasi sequel
Morris Mets had to deal with some
corporate influence studio executives
were opposed to letting news play J
again and instead wanted the more
experienced and the bankable Seth Green
to step into the role met convinced you
yo executives of Muse was right for the
role that he originated but the studio
still kept screen on cool for the
duration of the shoot as an understudy
should things not work out for Muse to
add insult to injury the studio also
refused to pay per Muse to travel to the
set in Minnesota or for his hotel room
during the shoot studio executives even
showed up to the first day of filming
fully prepared to fire Muse if they
didn't think he was good enough Smith
made Musa ware of the situation
prompting him to give us good at
performance out he could and the suits
finally approved well before Todd did
you purchase dogmatic after Gramercy's
reluctance to cast muse he showed up on
the set of Smith's next movie extra
prepared he memorized all his lines
before shooting on Dogma began along
with everybody else's it memorized the
entire script this was because Smith met
with news before rehearsals and told him
that he needed to do his best to work
because not only was Dogma the biggest
production that ever embarked on but
they had real actors in the movie this
time namely the legendary Alan Rickman
Muse showed up and gave his performance
everything he had because as he puts it
he didn't want to piss off that Rickman
dude life imitating art despite
memorizing the entire script for Dogma
Muse still had trouble filming the movie
because he was deeply addicted to heroin
at the time of shooting in a series of
blog posts Smith the detailed the times
during the shoot when a muse was
especially far gone because it's visible
in the film in the scene when the
Apostle Rufus was delivering his
backstory outside the movies for example
Jay struggles to keep himself from
nodding off a telltale sign of a heroin
hi mayor works tirelessly for years to
try and help his friend kick the habit
after several failed attempts Smith
invited Muse to live with him and his
family but Muse returned the favor by
stealing Smith's bank card and using the
money to buy heroin
didn't give up though checking amuse
into rehab climbing again he has
reportedly been drug-free since 2010 and
is now happily married with the child
clerks the animated series in 2000
Disney owned ABC commissioned an
animated series based on clerks while
the film's dialogue and plot points are
downright filthy that kind of thing just
wasn't going to fly on prime-time
network television as a result the
family-friendly network required some
alterations from the source material
among them
Jay and Silent Bob are not drug dealers
on clerks the animated series rather
they're just kind of pranksters who hang
out by the quick stop and occasionally
self I was the kid hi I'm Jay and I'm
Silent Bob and I'm Charles Barkley the
hell are you doing here only two
episodes aired before ABC cancelled it
scream over the years Jay and Silent Bob
have made a number of guest appearances
in television and film including on
Degrassi at the next generation and in
the 2000 film scream 3 Miramax do you
head Bob Weinstein accord Smith and told
him he had an idea for a Jay and Silent
Bob cameo in the movie Smith's came up
with some lines for the scene on the
spot while Muse was down because he
liked the $300 per diem and free t-shirt
he told Smith we should do this all the
time we can pop up in every horror movie
and get 300 bucks a day and a shirt
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you're looking
[Applause]